push to vaccinate kids could help get
families together this holiday season
more than 360 000 children under the age
of 12 have already received their first
dose now the white house is enlisting
schools to help make sure all kids get
the shot nikki batista is outside an
elementary school in new york city with
how this works nikki good morning
nate good morning this elementary school
in new york city like schools across the
country is offering covet 19 vaccines to
students on their way to class it's just
one of the steps school districts are
taking to encourage vaccinations
with this vaccine we can take away at
least one of your worries a big one
surrounded by students and parents in
virginia first lady dr jill biden
launched the administration's school
children vaccination campaign please
make the decision to protect your
children
with the same vaccine that has already
saved millions of lives
she spoke at the historic franklin
sherman elementary where the polio
vaccine was first administered to kids
in schools almost 70 years ago in 1954.
it's safe it's free and it's available
for every child in this country the
administration is also encouraging
school districts to use coronavirus
relief money to organize vaccine clinics
for students
[Applause]
vaccine clinics like the one at ps19 in
lower manhattan
this is exciting and very much
anticipated and we're happy that it's
here dan dominic is the executive
director of the american association of
school administrators he says the sooner
more children are vaccinated the sooner
restrictions will ease
do you anticipate
schools across the country might be
masculine by the end of this school year
there will be many buildings and many
districts that will be and those will be
the ones that made the effort and got
the larger percentage of the students
and staff vaccinated
the goal of the biden administration's
initiatives is to provide reliable
information and access for parents who
may be hesitant to vaccinate their kids
a new kaiser family foundation poll
shows 78 percent of adults say they have
heard at least one of eight different
false statements about covet 19 and that
they either believe it to be true or are
unsure if it's true or false tony wow
boy that's interesting but a lot of
parents were rooting for a mask-free
future for their kids in school that's
for sure nikki thank you very much